foreign
is trying to stop him right do you see
that
stopping stopping
So eventually he's going to get through
like that
so as I said
if if I have to stop him and he wants to
come forward
so rather than stop him it's it's as
he's pushing that angle you take him to
the tilt
not here but take it into the tilt
if this is an easy one is just take it
into a tilt
now you can do different things with
this hat
you see
so he's in it till he'll respond to it
into the other two
he pushes tilt
push his tilt
not here
eventually he's gonna get me
so he pushes tilts tilts
so if you look at this hand I came
around this way he went around the
outside and then I just stayed on the
inside
but the difference was that as he did
that this time I brought into the Tilt
do you see
and then I can use his hand now
so again he was pushing
so I just pushed that hand there his
hand attempted to counter I stay on the
inside out it goes
so if you look you push I just went and
took it in but it's kind of stuck do you
feel it it's kind of stuck are you
pushing push it gets stuck
on the other one right I'm trying to
take it he goes around the outside I
don't care I'll figure it out it doesn't
matter if you change it okay so this
time it went on this way I'd come around
this way
pushing
I'm on the inside
John came this way he went around the
outside I stayed on the inside okay do
you feel the same friction
so yeah but not here
so let's look at it he is coming around
I'm here
so let's look at that little circle
there's my yield but it's taking him
into that tilt do you see and once you
have one part of the Tilt here's where
the Coq on the x pattern works
now imagine I did that same one I'll
figure I don't know if I'm doing the
same thing here but I don't do this hand
into the tail I don't know I hold him up
and he's trying to go around this hand
you're trying to go around this hand
you're pushing on this hand I'm holding
you there look
he goes around this hand it won't be the
same thing you see that it will not be
the same thing it's this part that made
it work okay
so again as he goes I don't push I don't
stop him where does he want to go I can
feel him you see I can feel him go that
way so I let him go that way this is
letting him go that way
I don't know why you put yourself in a
wrist lock but okay
no tilt you see
same thing till
okay so you gotta hit that tilt can't be
sit sitting up right he's up right here
kind of just moving his arms around okay
try it again
why do you think he's floating like that
because what because I'm holding him up
all right let's see
is look he looks happy there yes yes
okay so you you used it phrase you're
holding him up
and he looks heavy
what would you say is happening
are you pushing on them yeah you're
pushing on them do you see he wants to
fall but you want him to fall another
way
okay and that hands you're pushing on
him so you got to lose the way you want
him to fall you don't want a way to have
no way
can't give up your Center Line though
you're pushing his chest you're you're
not doing some zombie thing you're doing
yeah
you and you can push one hand both hands
you don't have to always push both hands
and we don't we don't want to move in
this drill okay that way that way it
emphasizes the test of baki otherwise
we'd be standing up you can use foot
Maneuvers all all day long okay
all right so Andrew I would say what's
happening is is you have an external
yield but you have to be your yield
remember has to be in the center do you
feel that do you see
I'm not going he pushes I go like that
not just getting out of the way I
immediately touch his Center so when he
counters
you can keep touching anything
okay
oh touch his Center
then it'll work
just here won't work because he starts
leaning on you
which is what you want because that
makes his Center but if you're external
he's leaning on you he's actually going
to push push on you externally okay but
you do want
because what the UK does is they feel
that and then he starts using me for
balance and that's good because you can
just stop you see that that's what I
mean like I don't I don't my goal is not
to overpower him so I wouldn't want to
push him out of his fall
so when he's totally leading on you he's
falling you just take away the handrail
and they'll fall okay
so
same thing there's the push there's the
center
always in the center you see that never
out on his arms never out on his arms
and then I pull the arm and eventually
his shoulder and then eventually the
center that's not it
always in the center always
in the center
okay let's try it again
foreign
dude try to do that one again I want you
to show what I want to talk about what's
happened
I get the elbow okay now you feel his
center right
do you okay we'll push to it okay there
you go and now what you do is you've
picked the angle and the throw that you
want right do you get that but he's kind
of leaning forward do you see that and
is he resists and tries to keep his
balance go ahead that's when you just
outpower him
do you understand that but why are we
outpowering
what did I say you were doing
you had you had to just you already had
to throw a plan you already see the
throw in your head do you see that and
so now you're trying to force it but the
situation has changed
should I show you what I mean
we'll come on this side so I'll do the
same side that we have all right I don't
know what you're doing on this town but
you had this hand here
you see and you're like there it is but
he's pushing on it you see that and so
as you're pushing on it that's that's
our Center connection do you understand
that's your young energy and so I could
I could take it this way all right you
see that all right
so you had to throw there there it is
but he pushed into it well that's it now
there's this
so I you you guys watched like how
seamless effortless it is you won't even
know that he tried to do that okay but
once I feel oh this guy this guy pushed
into my Center they never did
and it's easy peasy okay drop but now
answer me
what actually made it difficult and what
actually made it easy
uh being stuck on one vector and one
pattern that's what makes it difficult
and what makes it easy
uh not not being so releasing yourself
okay so I as you're going and you feel
it oh there if you see it I'm like I'll
get you back you see that but anyone
that's pushing into you what energy is
that
so you turn it
and then easy peasy okay to push him
back on young as young young class very
difficult to do unless you're bigger
than that person but it's not Aikido
it's not Jiu Jitsu okay so you have to
bring this to that spirit level where
you'll feel the desire and you have to
release it and instead keep the
relationship okay so go back to that
technique
so you get what I'm talking about so as
we're going this part feels good let's
do the one you did with uh Gabriel do
you see that okay so watch watch and
you'll go slow so you can see because
you push that part felt good to you you
see that
and now it's starting to feel like [\h__\h]
all right do you see that right so
instead as this part feels good to you
keep the good feeling
do you understand
feelings what are you feeling you're
feeling for that uh reconciliation of
Yin and young okay all right try it
again
don't hold them
all right
so remember if you're if you hold me up
then I'm going to
not fall into any void does that make
sense are you you're like I'm trying to
touch your chest and you don't want me
to touch your chest you're holding I
can't go any more forward you're bigger
and stronger than me I can't go forward
see so I'm not in any tilt
then
you could have someone I guess who is
like driving and you get out of the way
do you see and then I fall into it
yes okay but it's probably not going to
be Tristan okay
um
so that's where that adhesion is gonna
come in okay and because I need the
friction I need that the
the stuckness okay so as you're trying
to touch me uh I am sticky you see
sticky and so uh with the stickiness
then the person who's maybe I'm holding
up do you think or the person who's not
going to give that much opening I can
get just an inch
using and this is literally a game of
inches all right
so if I push I'll be over young and I
won't be sticky except at the right
angles so as soon as he tried you try to
get off of that right angle you see I I
you felt that little slip there okay uh
and then what happened we'll do that one
again so on the right angle of course
I'm stuck but once you get off the right
angle look where I ended up okay do you
see and that was what was happening a
lot to you okay and remember in this
game because I want to understand the
keyho noaza testabaki I want to float
around the wrist and the and the Hand
range I don't want to come up to the
elbows for other Ledges okay so I'm I'm
stuck and I wait and I just match I
match what you're doing you see and you
can feel like it's almost like there's
tentacles on me because as you're
rolling around I feel different parts
sticking so right here it's there on
that thumb here it's in the palm and as
you move right it's over here now on the
pinky finger do you see and it's up
higher here on the knuckles okay so I'm
feeling that kind of stuff and but I
every time you move I'm letting it go
you see Let It Go but I I get in the
sticky part so there's a little tilt I
get you to respond to it by pushing a
little oh okay there we go right
and but you can feel the friction again
you feel like that man that does a stuck
hand okay then you'll do something to
get off of that there we go and there we
are
so don't over yawn which will always
happen when you try to stop him
especially with right angles so don't
seek your right angles
seek the stickiness
sticky you can feel how it just gets
like velcro a little bit okay
foreign
stuck again it even went okay
and that's by Not Over yamming You
matching your yawn Matt there it is
right there magic you can feel our skins
moving okay that's what from matching
your y'all okay
um
match match
so if you're moving your hand around but
you can see I'm just sticking to it okay
it's not it's impossible
for you to move your hand around like
move your hand around in the circle for
me to stay up with it but if I'm stuck
to it if you feel it again the skin gets
moving as you move they're not you're
just moving me
trying to stay up with it it's not gonna
hatch the same thing on the arms for me
to see what your arms are not going to
work but if I'm stuck there it is that
skin again if I'm stuck to it then I can
stay with you so as you try to get off
of it I feel the stickiness what happens
you get it so I've worked more by field
by feeling and not by sight okay and I'm
just matching that feel good feeling
see the harmonization of Yin and Yong
that's where the communion happens
that's the IQ there
um
and again there's a lot of you know a
lot of people are you're just supposed
to feel it yeah yeah you are supposed to
feel it because you can't see it you
can't see it even he can't see it but he
can feel his skin being moved you see as
we're stuck there so you can feel the
adhesion uh that's why I use that word
and have you look for it because you
can't feel it but you can't see it okay
so you have to be fine with the teacher
telling you feel it yeah I I [\h__\h]
feel it yeah I feel it okay and now you
have to chase the feeling not chasing
what you're seeing okay right right
again
so do you feel the pushing or is it or
do you hide it from yourself okay
right there
right there right there
there
so remember there's three elements or
aspects to your being you have your
physical being
and you have your energetic being
and then you have your spiritual
aspect your spiritual being okay
and in Aikido you train in all three of
them
can't train anyone
so you have something
in the Zen tradition called coans
and sometimes it's translated as riddle
but that's not a good a good uh term for
us it's not a riddle
it's not like what's green and red and
it's going 100 miles per hour frog in a
blender it's not that okay
they're really like
um chokes or igniters or catalysts for
the egoic mine
so you would do all your Zen training
and you would uh
practice your meditation do your
cleaning do all your rituals Etc you
would do your servitude uh you'd Place
yourself into the social hierarchy you
take on that pohi roll
and you would work on cultivating
humility and releasing of the self Etc
and then eventually you're going to go
in and the Abbott is going to give you a
co-on
and what it is is it's it's something
that that Abbott knows will spark your
ego tripartite mind
and the Abbott knows in their experience
how to read
the functioning of the ego tripartite
mind okay
so the Albert would give you one of
these things that triggers your ego
tripartite mind
a Virginia you know the hand of two-hand
clapping what's the hand of what's the
sound of one hand
you know the sound of two hands what's
the sound of one hand what is it what is
it
so the nodding
affirmation there's no affirmation to
that thing and I don't know there's
nothing to know
you see but the conversation the word
selection the body language the
proxemics all that stuff
it's going to be a catalyst for the
functioning of the ego tripartite mine
and then the master goes not enough
you're saying you go back to your
practices
in Aikido
we don't use the colon we use the push
the push is going to be that same spark
that same Catalyst that will trigger
your ego tripartite mind
how are you triggered the master is
going to know how how what that looks
like so what do you think it looks like
what do you think how is how does it
manifest itself
say it loud enough go for it what
tension in the body right non-acceptance
do you see that
uh if I have non-acceptance then I have
preference
do you see so I have desire I have want
I have something I'm trying to avoid
it's something I'm trying to have and
what does that look like what does that
look like because that was your thing
yeah like you're pushing you're young
young clashing you see do you get that
uh what how else does it manifest
what other signs of tension
non-acceptance young young clashing will
you see in the Desi
holding breath right right
um
tense and stuff jaw clenching uh face
flexing all of those things right the
movement is not relaxed and effortless
right
uh what else about the movement what
will the movement do do you think it's
going to look like this
if I'm in the god mine am I didn't look
like this
short chopping
geometric movement no it's going to be
flowing and circular and spiral do you
understand right what's going to happen
to my base of support
it's going to go up right I hold my
breath I put tension in my shoulder and
I start to rise up as my glutes and my
legs start to flex because of the fear
response right all that stuff has to
happen do you guys get it okay so in a
way as you're going here this is your
cool your co-auth
oh and we don't want to see
that you see we want to see the god mind
stay happening
if you're my hands
you can't look at my house look how
relaxing
[Music]
foreign
training that's what that's what we're
doing but it's energetically it's not
intellectual you're the functioning of
your intellect is the functioning of
your egoic mind but young clashing
energy that's also the functioning of
your egoic mind okay